what's going on guys this is rob and
we've got about a month and a half or so
until the new hawkeye trailer drops so
we thought it'd be fun to make a video
basically ranking the mcu shows that
have come out so far right the four
shows that we've gotten in our order of
which one we think is the least
interesting to the best of the shows
something else to keep in mind this is
the exact order this is the correct
order and no other order is correct
i'm just messing with you guys although
i know some of you guys are gonna post
your comments believing that this is my
order and it's the correct order and
anybody who agrees with my order is
wrong
so let's get right into this right so
coming into the number four spot on this
and i feel like we need a ranking system
here or some kind of a a rating system
so we'll call the rating system geeks
right we use our little geek culture
explain logo i think that'd be kind of
cool so editor alex make sure you put
that in there coming in at number four
with i don't know pick a lower arbitrary
number
four geeks
falcon in the winter soldier so falcon
of the winter soldier was okay right
this show was was interesting enough it
was interesting enough to keep me coming
back every week but it wasn't like the
coolest thing there ever was which is
kind of surprising coming off the heels
of one division now something that i do
recognize here is i know that they had
already essentially finished falcon in
the winter soldier or were for the most
part done by the time juan division
finished so it's not as though they had
just started the writing process for
falcon of the winter soldier as one
division was finishing and they could
take those compelling themes from one
division and roll them over into falcon
of the winter soldier and even if they
could have i doubt they would have
falcon of the winter soldier was a
straightforward show it was not messy it
was not fussy there were no real twists
and turns and i think that is ultimately
what took away from it that with wand
division it was really exciting we'll
talk more about that here in a minute
but that show is exciting with falcon in
the winter soldier if this show was a
road it'd basically be a road in kansas
that goes straight for like 80 miles and
there's a couple turns here and there
enough to make you wonder what's on the
other side of that turn but not enough
to really be surprised by whatever
happens to be there right i mean you
kind of know so there were a few things
that i thought were interesting the idea
of the power broker i didn't see the
idea that like sharon carter was a power
broker as being a big plot twist i
thought it was cool but at the end of
the day when it comes down to that show
it was the closest we got to a marvel
cinematic universe movie and tv form was
it entertaining yes do i consider it to
be the best of the mcu shows so far no
it was just a cool show that we watched
for a while while we were just basically
waiting for loki to come out and that
brings us into number three coming with
we'll say like four and a half geeks
what if now i still stick by my
statement on the what if review that i
did
yesterday or the day before whenever it
was right like no amount of youtube
comments is gonna change that sorry
about your luck i thought what if was
okay was it a show that was fun to watch
yeah sure i had a great time watching it
was it a show where some of the episodes
were just absolutely phenomenal yes
definitely was it a show that i felt
like what happened over the course of
the entire series matters
no and again i stick by my statement
that if the what if season finale had
had some kind of a tie-in to the mcu if
it had invoked something of the mcu that
the watcher had basically kind of been
there watching everything unfold with
regards to some of the events or any of
the events in the main marvel cinematic
universe if we had some reference to
loki or kane the conqueror or the living
tribunal or any number of options that
we could pick from that would have said
hey like this is going to continue on in
some form or fashion into the future of
the mcu possibly tying into the events
of doctor strange too or something along
those lines that would have been
interesting that would have been cool
right like wanda from the mcu from from
one division just comes flying through
at the end of like the post-credits
scene right like she wipes out a world
or something like that or destroys uh
again i don't know destroys the whole
universe who knows who cares but if
there had been some kind of a tie-in to
the greater mcu it would have given the
show significance such as it is if i
were to have never seen this show it
would make no difference or have any
kind of bearing whatsoever on anything
regarding the mcu and that's what
disappoints me the most is because when
it comes to the marvel cinematic
universe as far as my theories go
anybody who's been on this channel long
enough knows i don't care if i'm right
or wrong i just like theorizing stuff
it's cool if i'm right that's awesome
but if i'm wrong who cares i had a great
time doing it
and so for that part i don't really care
but the popularity of the mcu from my
time having watched all these films from
ural's time having watched all these
movies is that in a lot of instances
everything builds on everything else
that you see these little cameos
appearances these little pop-up moments
here and there that basically tell us
this is going to tie into something
later on down the road there's some kind
of an involvement it's all a
interconnected cohesive universe the
what if series gave us nothing about
that right it was just a totally
self-contained series and if that's what
it's going to be cool i guess based on
the first season we can kind of assume
that's going to be the case given the
response to it and i'd like to believe
there that it's more than just me who
feels that way that there might be some
potential for season two to have a
little more involvement with the rest of
the mcu but maybe it never does i mean
the entirety of the what if series and
the comics never had anything to do with
anything going on in the main marvel
universe outside of the fact that it was
a story based on what would have
happened if things happened differently
but it's not like there were ever really
any instances where you got to the end
of a what-if story in marvel comics and
it ties back into the main marvel
universe itself doesn't usually happen
that way i mean i guess maybe a couple
times it does but not on any real level
of regularity so i guess it does make
sense given the what if show that it
would be totally self-contained but the
fact that it was self-contained and
isolated disappointed me right having
said that just because of the fact that
we got to see like marvel zombies which
was amazing because we got to see the
whole story of like evil doctor strange
right the the whole thing with like
ultron taking the body of vision getting
the infinity stones just those three
episodes right there are what put what
if ahead of falcon in the winter soldier
if those episodes didn't exist this
would be all the way down to the very
bottom but having said that given this
thing like four and a half geeks and
we're gonna call it a day so that moves
us into number two
which is
one division and i'm sure a lot of
people would be like what that's
ridiculous right keyboard warriors
furiously typing away at their keyboard
just raging in youtube comments i'm
sorry one division was a cool show and
and in reality it's kind of hard to find
any real faults in the show but there
are a few here and there most notably
and most obviously the first couple of
episodes they were a bit too slow it
started off a little too slow for its
own good and actually drove people away
one of the most important things you
learn by being a youtube content creator
or anybody who creates any kind of
content in the digital or analog space
is that you usually have about five
seconds to catch people's attention at
the beginning of the video if you don't
get it most people are gone when it
comes to tv shows you get about one or
two episodes if you can't catch people's
attention in one or two episodes they
move on to something else right people's
attention span is exceedingly short in
this day and age because there's just a
huge influx of stuff out there that's
pulling their attention in different
ways right so we are long gone from the
days of like the 1980s and cheers right
this is not that case anyway it's not
that time period anymore right so the
first couple episodes were a little too
slow having said that most everything
else about the show was great it was fun
and it was interesting i wish we had
gotten to see a little more use of
wanda's powers but if all in all
honestly i'm kind of splitting hairs at
this point because what we got was
really cool and it was really
interesting i like to see her use her
powers in that capacity it wasn't too
grand of a gesture it wasn't
astronomically insane it wasn't like she
was wiping you know or altering reality
on like a universal scale so it wasn't
anything as gaudy and huge as house of m
it was small and it was localized but
what made one division so cool is that
the entire show and it's not really even
something that i thought of until after
the show had gone off the air and i'd
seen somebody make a twitter post about
it the whole show is basically wanda
just coming to terms with loss right
having lost vision having lost her
brother quicksilver having just lost
things over and over and over again and
then doing everything she can to just
hold on to what little she has left
that's the whole idea of the show that
touched me personally right just because
of my own personal life experience and
the losses that i've endured and so i
totally understood where that came from
and i loved that whole thing the one
thing that holds this show back from
taking the number one spot right the one
thing that holds the show back and i
know i'm nitpicking here i don't care
the engineer
should have been adam beshear it
absolutely should have been adam for
sure there's no reason it shouldn't have
been him right adam beshear is amazing i
love the character of adam brazier and i
will hold that against the show right i
will let me tell you something i'm petty
i will name names right if a show does
something that i don't that i'm not a
big fan of like the engineer should have
been adam brosher oh i'll hold that
against the show forever let me tell you
something man one i wouldn't say one
division's name is mud in my book but
like that should have happened and i'm
gonna hold that grudge against one
division forever
you can be mad at me all you want to i
don't care that's just the way it is i'm
gonna hold that grudge right but that's
like the one thing that kept it taking
the number one spot now having said that
i'd give it like like a solid 4.9 geeks
right i mean this thing's almost perfect
but the number one spot as you guys know
belongs to loki this was a phenomenal
show loki nailed every single mark along
the way i love this thing right one
because of the way that just tom
hiddleston plays loki but two it didn't
rely on a lot of the tropes that we know
of with loki i mean to a degree it did
but that went out of the way with a
quickness right in episode number one
that was done because that was my fear
my fear going into the first episode is
oh my god it's basically going to be
loki from like thor or like from
avengers where he's basically just kind
of a goof who's a little bit of a dick
sometimes he does like an occasional
nice thing that's just going to be this
whole show no no i love the way they
handled that right where he had like go
back he went back and watched his own
future and saw that like because of his
actions he gets his mom killed that
right there was the turning point and
then you got to see the serious part of
loki right what's loki capable of when
he actually puts his mind to task and
it's serious you know i loved that whole
thing the character of sylvie i loved it
you know one of the things that i've
kind of noticed about myself over the
years i prefer the mystery and intrigue
kind of a side track here is a really
good example do you guys remember the
show heroes back in the day heroes was a
was an amazing show i loved the
character of syler before they developed
him i loved him when he was just the
shadowy guy who was going around killing
people with superpowers and then
stealing them right and then collecting
them i love that when he decided like
his hat forward like that you could
never see his face he wore like a black
trench coat it was weird that he made
lockers fly off the wall and attack
peter patrelli but still you know i love
that whole element for for some reason
or another i don't really know why i
prefer it when like the main villain is
just kind of a shadowy you know mystery
figure because there's no real identity
to find there and a lot of is probably
because my imagination can just run wild
and so while i wasn't really huge on the
idea of sylvie actually getting a face
and getting a name and getting a
backstory i do think that the story that
we got was cool in relation to the fact
that the tva usually causes their own
problems right that they can cause they
can create a lot of issues for
themselves and sylvie was a perfect
example of it having said that what i
think really puts loki over the top as
cool as the stories were and as awesome
as a lot of the fight scenes were and as
fantastic as the relationship between
owen wilson and tom hiddleston was which
was absolutely phenomenal what i really
think puts this over the top is the
world building the idea of immortus the
the guy that we never saw coming in the
show i can't think of a single person
who could honestly state that they
expected to see immortus at the end of
of the loki's show i think a lot of
people hypothesized king the conqueror
or something like that and if we ever
saw maybe some kind of a post-credit
scene or some kind of a little cameo or
something at like the telltale end right
so like the last minute and a half for
the show but like the whole notion of
the time keepers and all that kind of
stuff i thought that was about as far as
it went i was like okay so we get to see
the time keepers are actually real all
right cool like that's that's basically
it and that was just the tip of the
iceberg then they find immortals right
and that was crazy the world building i
think is what really sets this show
apart because pretty much everything
that we've seen so far going into the
marvel cinematic universe post loki is
all based on loki i still stand by the
idea that the post-credits scene for
venom 2 is based on loki i still stand
by the idea that the whole idea of dr
strange's spell going awry happens
because of loki that it wasn't really
supposed to work that way and it wasn't
really peter screwing up the spell i
mean maybe it was but i feel like that
coincides with the actions of loki and
the multiverse coming back and basically
he just cast a spell at the wrong time
right like a car wreck at an
intersection just things just kind of go
belly up and everything goes nuts and
then the whole movie unfolds and in
spider-man 3. right i mean when it comes
to this kind of thing when it comes to
the show of loki i feel like the ending
of this and everything that it did
bringing in the multiverse and all that
kind of stuff perfectly encapsulates
what makes the marvel cinematic universe
the marvel cinematic universe world
building crossovers appearances cameos
the whole nine yards i loved it i
absolutely loved it so having said that
guys that's our list that's our ranking
for the four marvel tv shows so far i'm
sure a lot of you guys probably disagree
with it let me know what you think down
in the comments section although i don't
really have to ask you right i mean it
is the internet right like people are
compelled to give their factual answers
which i use in place of opinions oh loki
five geeks just perfect across the board
so how do you say that guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace